[Music]
what's the problem I think you know what
the problem is just as well as I do I
did it
you did what I saw it shining in the
bottom of the dish pure radium metal oh
yes okay so let's do the math I have
enough food to last for 50 days so I'm
gonna have to science the [ __ ] out of it
the structure of DNA is secret of life
itself life unfolding right in front of
the first achievement alarms and cured
her place in history well each other we
could see everything
really see it I'm kind of an ancient
figure now wheeled out on special
occasions as a curiosity I have reached
an age when if someone tells me to wear
socks I don't have to I'm a cosmologists
what's that I study the marriage of
space and time
just a mathematician sometimes it is
people who no one imagines anything of
who do things that no one can imagine
yes I thought if we were going to
publish it should be something
groundbreaking this is my second this
will take a lifetime
maybe two
[Music]
and and what we've just seen is an
example of what I think could be the
biggest bravest challenge to
screenwriters and playwrights everywhere
and that is turning science into art as
you just saw many have taken on the
artistic challenge of portraying the
human side of science a Nobel
prize-winning physicist confronting his
own mortality the woman who first
glimpsed the structure of life but was
nearly forgotten by history the man who
could see infinity and then put it down
on paper those were the objetive
subjects of a number of those films
these are not the usual plot lines that
Hollywood undertakes or Broadway and yet
these are powerful stories that have to
be told stories that are just as
memorable and just as meaningful as
those from the world of politics in
medicine and at their core all of these
stories are simply about human beings
human beings fulfilling their destinies
and making connections with other human
beings this afternoon we're going to
hear from five people who have
successfully tackled such intimidating
topics as quantum physics number theory
and DNA to tell the larger-than-life
stories of the humans behind the science
and let me introduce them first needing
no introduction but I'll give it anyway
Alan Alda besides being a dear friend of
this festival
[Applause]
I heard my name and I came out Allen is
of course a seven-time Emmy
award-winning actor for some show that
you may have seen on television and a
number of other things on Broadway he
appeared as a physicist Richard Fineman
for the play QED he is also the force
behind the Alan Alda Center for
communicating science at Stony Brook
University let's have another hand now
we have Matt Brown who is the director
and the screenwriter of the film here's
a little bit a clip of it called the man
who knew infinity which tells the story
of the East Indian the East the East
Indian mathematician Ramanujam it stars
Dev Patel and Jeremy Irons and it is as
they said say now playing as a theater
near you I have seen it it is wonderful
run do not walk take everyone you know
our next panelist is Alan Lightman
allan lichtman is a writer an
astrophysicist and an educator he is the
first professor at MIT to receive a
joint appointment in science and the
humanities he's the author of the novel
I'm Stein's dreams which has been
translated into 30 languages and several
other art forms Allan Lichtman also to
this with us today is Peter Parnell is
the author and the playwright and among
as many works are the plays QED
which starred Alan Alda as the physicist
Richard Fineman and the play trumpery
not about what you think it's about the
chairs the story of Charles Darwin and
the theory of evolution
Peter Parnell and finally because it
looks as if this actually alphabetically
of Anna's eager Anna is the author of
among other plays photograph 51 you saw
a bit of a clip of that as well was
staged in London last year with Nicole
Kidman playing the scientist rosalind
Franklin Anna knows this campus very
well as she received her MFA in dramatic
writing from NYU so welcome home so Matt
let me start with you if I may there is
no shortage of human drama in scientists
we all know that scientists like
everybody else fall in love and they as
the cliche goes put their pants on one
leg at a time maybe or if their skirts
they die young they win the Nobel Prize
or not but for playwrights and
screenwriters the challenge is to tell
the stories of these remarkable people
in a way that not only captures it
accurately and factually but also makes
it interesting to the audience so tell
us a little bit about the challenges you
faced and bringing Ramanujan's story to
the film sure well I'm not a
mathematician so I should start by
saying that and for me I
that mathematics was something that
growing up always felt a little esoteric
and a little austere and it was it was
as far away for so originally I came to
this story interested in the human
element as so often I think writers do
when they approach really any subject
that said I I came to an understanding
of the mathematicians the pure
mathematicians in this story the man I
knew infinity pure mathematics I saw it
as an art form and I realized that their
passion for their art of mathematics was
something I could relate to in my own
life as a writer and a director and it
was something that I thought we could
tap into and help a general audience
people who like myself for not
mathematicians be able to relate to and
start to see mathematicians as people
which I think frankly often they're not
portrayed always portrayed as like the
crazy scribbling or depressed or
whatever it would be and and these men
worked that way Ramanujan wasn't some
very eccentric crazy out there person he
was a human with a human story and and
great courage and it was it was
something that he wasn't I didn't have
to make him wacky I don't have to make
him I just had to show his passion for
what he does and when and how did you
discover the story to begin with well I
came across the biography by written by
Robert cannibal which was an incredible
biography and I I was drawn to it
because of the historical aspects I was
interested in the Great War at the time
I'd read a book called birdsong by
Sebastian fall loved it and then when I
came to infinity that was also set
against the Great War and that
originally drew my interest and then it
was this human story about a man who for
him an equation had no meaning unless it
expressed the thought of God and he
broke cast to go to England at the turn
of the century faced incredible
prejudice and he is received on the
other end of it by a man who is
emotionally completely unavailable and
an atheist to boot so it was a human
drama that was we should point out that
the the real Ramanujan is is is on the
screen behind you I believe okay when
you when you
who decided to do this how concerned
were you about the idea that numbers and
mathematics might put people off and
might scare moviegoers away um I was
less concerned about it then say the
financier is a lot of other people I
mean it took me 10 years to get the
movie financed and it was a real
challenge it was something that at one
point a financier said well couldn't
Ramanujan fall in love with a white
nurse while he's in I was like no he
can't
authenticity to me was incredibly
important it was important that the
mathematics were treated authentically
as well as culturally as much as you
know there's always going to be some
liberties but but nothing outrageous and
I felt like the mathematics if it was
addressed and it played a role in the
storytelling then it was essential to as
essential to who he is so and to their
relationship so I you know I looked at
their relationship and for them for the
story to me was about the cost that
comes when two people wait out of fear
to connect in their relationships and at
the center of that was these ideological
issues and it all centered around
mathematics it was about proof and how
much how much math did you actually wind
up having to learn and learning as a
result of this quite a bit it was
philosophically Robert canticle who
wrote the biography felt like if I
didn't wrap my head around it then he
wasn't going to allow me to have have
the book to begin with so something that
that was important to him in the
beginning and it was important to me I
wasn't afraid of that aspect of it I
just wanted you know I wanted to find a
way to let an audience understand it
without having to flash numbers across
the screen and like you know make it
into some kind of write I don't know
something that wasn't authentic to it or
with a lot of graphics all the time
right so you know we were lucky in the
sense that they did work on partitions
which is something that I think most of
us can grasp at least what the question
is or the problem so we we did that and
then the big challenge was also for
Ramanujan this was a man who when he was
13 he went to school one day and he had
discovered trigonometry and abaya
discover
I mean he actually discovered the whole
field so he went into school and he said
I've discovered trigonometry and they
said we already know what that is and it
actually exists as a field you know so
he he didn't waste time with proofs he
was always on to the next and the next
and he was coming up with whole realms
of mathematics and theories which is
it's pretty incredible you can't really
explain that same thing and for Hardy
his his opposite in Cambridge he was a
man of rigor and he really truly
believed in in rigor as a discipline for
mathematics it was essential and it
probably was to a degree but I mean if
had we known Ramanujan was gonna pass so
young maybe you would have just let him
run died at age 32 I think it was right
so I think at the center of this is a
philosophical question of proof and and
rigor and that was something that played
a big role in the creative writing of
this story and it's a perfect segue to
Peter because in QED of course you focus
on Richard Fineman the man who taught us
so very much QED stands for quantum
electrodynamics did you have any second
thoughts about putting that up on the
theater marquee no but is are there
periods or not that's like--you period e
period the period is something else
right that's right tell us about why you
thought this story needed to be on the
stage oh sure in this was a case a
project that came to me because I was
working on I'd done an adaptation of a
John Irving novel a two-part a petition
at the that was done it see how it were
developed at Seattle rabiner that was
it's at her house Tiger House Rules yes
exactly and then it was done at the
taper in LA and Gordon Davidson who was
an artistic director came to me and said
there's a book that Alan Alda is
interested in adapting if it's if
there's a way to do it for the stage for
him to play Richard Fineman and so I
actually I I read the book and didn't
have a clue as to how to do it but
the idea of working on a character like
Fineman from what I found from both that
book and then reading his other books
and of having Alan be the Fineman it was
so exciting to me that that's how how I
came to it after that actually figuring
out what the play was it took a very
long time and I actually wrote basically
six very different five or six very
different versions completely different
plays Oh Alan is shaking his head well
you say that live wrong we would Peter
would come to Gordon and me and say I
think I got it and we'd read it out loud
and it would be terrific but we'd say I
bet we could go deeper or there's there
aspects of Fineman was we could nail but
it was hard to nail Fineman down because
he was so many different people right he
had a wealth of characters in him so
Peter was I've never seen anybody so
indefatigable as Peter he literally
would go away and come back with a whole
other play a few months later and each
one got better than the last one
and finally there was one there was no
question it was so good and we were
finally able to open we had thought we
could open a year later I think it took
six years yeah yeah and but in the
course of this yeah
did you like Matt have to want to learn
physics have to yes yeah to some extent
I mean I'm also was terrible in in math
so the whole mathematics part of it but
you're dealing in metaphor and and if
you get to a point where you can have
some kind of conversation with people at
Cal Tech who knew Fineman and could you
know that was overwhelming for me
because I then I you know I could at the
end have but in the most basic basic way
but I wanted to add to what Alan was
saying which is that one of the
challenges with Fineman is that he was a
guy who knew which problems to try and
solve and he was very having Alan play
the the that part of him that was a
great teacher
and a great performer and very funny and
a raconteur was not that wasn't going to
be a problem but where was the [ __ ]
dramatically if there was in the armor
of a character who basically had all the
answers in front of him when what was
the question that he wasn't going to be
able to solve and we went back and forth
about this overdrafts because we came to
the point of saying if there's a guy who
is willing to embrace uncertainty and
doubt as part of the philosophy of his
life what do you do with that it where's
the conflict is that an inner conflict
is in an external and and tagging it
what where's the conflict that where's
the play and it was actually Alan put it
one day and saying you actually came to
a point of writing about a character who
began to doubt doubt if just for a
moment of wondering if I don't solve
this even though I'm fine with the fact
that I'm struggling and trying to get
I'm not well and I would love to be able
to solve my cancer but I can't what do
you do with that character and how do
you either have him to some extent lift
the veil a little bit dramatically No so
it's about the human I mean it gets back
to I said originally it was not about
the math it's not about the physics it's
about the human side and I must tell you
I covered the Rogers Commission hearings
into the Challenger explosion and I was
sitting in the audience when Fineman
famously dunked the piece of rubber from
the o-rings into the ice water and you
know in in a minute and a half explained
brilliantly what nobody else could
figure out a way to understand yeah so
that was part of his the idea was it
exactly really under if you really
understand something you should be able
to explain it in a simple interest at
are not simple but clear clear right but
and but now you chose to set your plate
towards the end of his life yes he did
so much why did you do that that was
part of that question about what where
what do you towards the end of his life
there was an interview we
Fineman in which he was asked about a
unified theory and did he feel that that
would be found one day and he was
talking about and he was talking about
nature and about the fact that he had
danced with nature you saw nature as a
woman in a way but she was never going
to fully lift her veil for him which is
where and he also tried to say in this
preview there probably won't be a theory
like that I won't be around for it
didn't in any way and but there was also
a little bit of her regret maybe anger
there in the there was something that we
could pick up on that was saying okay
what finally you are human
and you have to you go through something
we all go through in different ways be
salt that you will not solve and if you
can dramatize that even just for a
little bit in this case it's over the
course of a day and maybe there's you
know there's a way for an audience to
climb in Allen was your interest in in
in doing this being this character the
personal or the or the physics or the
science or was it a combination and a
way to communicate that I think it was
all of that and mm-hmm would what would
I'd love to do in the pieces I've
written or and this that that Peter
wrote what I'd love to take part in is a
chance to show the scientist as a fellow
human with flaws aspirations making this
why is that so important I think it's
very important because the distance that
we feel between us and scientists that
we've historically felt keeps us apart
from the work they do we say well these
special people wearing white coats with
their hair and bless already yeah you
know they're different from us they're
they're brainiacs
they're not like us but they are like us
we are them and we need to learn their
way of thinking we need to have an
evidence-based form of thinking just the
way they do we need to know the
difference between opinion
and something that you have evidence for
I mean our existence might depend on
that I'm just laughing because I was
about to say I think we're not meant to
get into politics
[Laughter]
I'd like to see the human side of
scientists come out and if it's possible
to show that a human obstacle or a human
flaw reveal something or is analogous in
some way to the science that they do
then you've got both at once now that's
really lucky when you can find that
combination and speaking of the human
side Richard Fineman famously played the
bongo drums yeah I hadn't learned that
it so so there's Richard Fineman so was
this also a way into his character and
by the way you say you also had to learn
I had to learn how to do it and I
foolishly made the mistake of saying to
Peter how about if he delivers this
whole monologue while he's drumming you
know it's like doing this you know do
you did you feel that you needed wanted
to do that to show his humanity or to
reach the audience well it was part of
how he was so many different people
right he was a safecracker he at Los
Alamos he would break into people's
safes and leave a little note
safecrackers struck again because he
wanted to show them he could do away
people hack into companies now to say
see you're vulnerable right so he wanted
to show them they were vulnerable but
meanwhile he was cracking into safes and
driving people crazy let's talk a little
bit about the plays that you have
written also it sounds as if you had a
fair amount of input bothered Peter he
wrote a flea
you wrote a play based on the letters of
Albert Einstein hmm and you wrote a play
about Marie Curie called radiance we saw
a bit of both in the opening video Marie
Curie's life in particular is very rich
material for a playwright why did she
strike you well because I knew it he was
the story of that I know a little about
her
and I thought we great for the world
science festival if I did a reading of
her letters because I thought through
her letters an interesting life would
come out and then I found out that her
letters are still in the library in
Paris and they're still radioactive and
you have to sign a piece of paper that
says roughly your understand cause it
could die
so I switch to Einstein and then and
then I I realized what a wonderful life
she really had and I decided to write a
full before kind of play about her what
was it about her life that's that struck
you know what it was
that really when I do more I learned
about Marie
and she became Marie to me you know I
felt very close to her she became for me
someone who simply wouldn't give up she
had so many obstacles in her life the
science itself the fact that she was
discovering radioactivity something she
didn't even know what it was it was by
accident she thought she was measuring
the radiation coming out of uranium and
then she realized it was radiation
coming out of stuff that had no uranium
in it so was it was a true discovery so
that was had a dig through seven tons of
ore herself and boiled it down it took
years and hard work and smelling the
acid fumes and then after all of that
she was facing the obstacle of being
considered just a woman she did most of
the work had the insights and they
wanted to give the Nobel Prize to her
husband so she had nothing but obstacles
but she never gave up and it's hard to
write a play and every time I spirits
which flag she was my hero and she was
the one in a way saying to me what
schmuck
don't give up funny that she was
so this is a perfect segue to Anna's
Anna's play which of course is about
another female scientist who faced very
similar misogyny shall we say Anna's
eager how did you come across rosalind
Franklin and what were your obstacles in
writing about a woman who was a
scientist in the 50s who was barely
known for a while right well I'm
embarrassed to say I'd never heard of
her um I was I was 26 and living in
Washington DC and I had just finished
grad school at NYU and a small theater
in Maryland that was just getting going
approached me to write a play that would
appeal to they wanted a series of plays
and wanted that would appeal to
different people in the in the sort of
local area and so mine would be the NIH
play and I don't know why they thought I
would be capable of doing this like some
of my fellow panelists I was not a
science or math person and in fact would
cry regularly during math tests until I
was older than I would like to admit but
uh but they approached me to write this
play about three female scientists and I
had heard of one of them that was Rachel
Carson but I'd never even read Silent
Spring and and two of them so Rachel
Carson and this other scientist named
Roger Young who was the first
african-american woman to get a PhD in
biology in the states had Maryland
connections and then they threw in
rosalind Franklin because she's
fascinating and as I started researching
this play that no one thought I should
write I yeah I was just really taken by
rosalind Franklin I couldn't believe
that I'd ever heard of her I just
thought she was she's kind of exactly I
mean there's so many even saying what
you look for in a great character very
human and very flawed what did where did
you find the research how did you get to
her
well because I I had to convince this
theater to let me
redo my assignment and get rid of the to
Maryland connected scientists I had to
write it really fast so I I mean it
there's a wonderful biography by Brenda
Maddox about rosalind Franklin and
there's a ton online I mean then there's
the double helix so I think probably the
double helix and and the Dark Lady of
DNA where my main sources for the first
draft of the play and and yeah I was
just I think similar to what Alan said
you know about about Curie there was you
know kind of a fascinating metaphor at
the heart of of the character and I
think for her it was you know the same
qualities that that led her to become a
successful female scientist in the 50s
when as you say there were so many
obstacles you know her independence her
strong will her perfectionism
intelligence obviously many of those
qualities were the same ones that held
her back in this sort of biggest race of
her professional life which she did not
even know she was a part of and she
didn't know she was a part of it because
she died so young well she didn't know
she was a part of it because I it was
there was a sort of a gentlemen's
agreement in England at the time that
different labs were not working on the
same material and so rosalind Franklin
felt pretty secure in the fact that her
lab at King's College was the only lab
working to discover the structure of DNA
at the time but of course Watson and
Crick and Watson being an American I did
not have that code was was was happy to
to try to steal some of the limelight at
the time so she didn't know that they
were working on it and then of course
she died before then she Nobel was
awarded she did but you chose not to
portray her as a victim we'll get into
more of that in a little bit but you
chose not to portray her as a victim in
the play it's not oh poor rosalind I
mean she's a very strong character yeah
I don't think she thought of herself as
a victim at all I think and
I think she had a lot of pride and in
some ways that was it as I said it
propelled her a great distance and then
it also held her back because she was
she didn't want to collaborate with this
man she didn't get along with and and I
think that had a lot to do with pride it
had a lot to do with other things too
and the sort of complicated reality of
the context in which she was working and
the stakes were higher for her certainly
because she was a woman if she you know
made an error I think it would have had
greater consequences then then certainly
for Watson and Crick let me just ask you
the same question I asked the others
which is did you have to learn did you
have a hard time learning about read you
were gonna ask me that I learned not
intentionally but probably the little
sciences I possibly could to get away
with writing this play and I faked my
weight but a lot of it I certainly know
more about DNA than I did going in but
there are concepts I could not explain
to you now that are in the play so I I
think in some ways it was it was an
asset not to not know a lot of it
because I couldn't put that much in the
play that I didn't understand so it
right it was therefore it therefore
became accessible to everyone because I
was like the lowest comment I just like
to say that when I covered the space
program program for ABC News I knew how
to land the space shuttle Allan Lichtman
this is not your problem learning about
your subject because you know all about
your subject you have a really unique
perspective on this and I'm for one year
I realized the person you wrote about
except for your one on site every but
most of these characters died reasonably
young in their lives Einstein obviously
lived much much longer I don't know if
that had anything to do with Einstein's
dreams the book that you the novel that
you wrote why did you do it as a novel
and what was your concept why did you
want to do it that way what can I make
one comment one observation before I
answer your question if you're gonna
tell me you had to learn the theory of
relativity no but we're all trying to
figure out here how to put
science into a work of art and have it
be compelling not didactic involve the
the viewer in in the human story and
you'll notice that the three well now
four people four plays books films we've
mentioned richard fineman ram anujan
roth and Franklin and Albert Einstein
that all of those works were about an
individual so that the the artistic
device there for making the work of art
is to focus around a person a central
person so that is is as often a very
good strategy for creating a work of art
and having it follow the human story
which were all interested in
I just wanted to point out that there's
a commonality right absolutely well and
there's an heiress because there's a
narrative there's a narrative where the
personal and if you're going to make say
a movie or a play about climate change
without featuring a particular
individual and there have been a number
of those made to you have a more
difficult tests in front of you so if
you're interested you're saying in
explaining the science go for the
individual as opposed to trying to
that's until a lecture on science that's
an easier path right so your your
question was why did I choose Einstein
right well I didn't set out to initially
to write about Einstein what happened
for me in that book is the the title
came to me Einstein's dreams it just
came into my consciousness somehow and
that title to me represented the the
conflict between our rational side and
our intuitive side with with Einstein
representing the rational logical
scientific side of us and dreams
representing our intuitive more
imaginative side although science has
plenty of event
wishing an imagination in it and a lot
of my thinking and writing life has been
trying to to deal or portray or
understand that full dimensionality of
human beings that we both have an
intuitive side a logic a intuitive
imaginative spontaneous side and we also
have a more deliberate rational side we
most of us have all of those things
combined innocent it's a it's a
fascinating comment or understanding
about what human beings are and so that
tension between the intuitive and the
rational which was what propelled mm-hmm
the book and of course then I I've been
a fan in general of the magic realist
writers people like Gabriel Garcia
Marquez anatella Calvino and Calvin you
know wrote a little book called
invisible cities I don't know maybe some
of you have read it but it's it's a it's
a fictitious fictitious book about
Genghis Khan's Empire and ginga's popcon
had such a big Empire that he didn't
even know everything it was in it so we
sent out the market the the explorer
Marco Polo to survey his empire and come
back and make reports and he makes each
report in a little chapter in the book
this is all fictional which is this
incredible vivid lyrical beautiful
imagine of description of one of the
cities and and Genghis Khan's Empire and
so I was sort of inspired by that book
at least it was in the back of my mind I
don't think we really know all of the
inspirations that cause us to create
something but that was one thing that I
can point to and so I decided to do what
for time what Calvino had done for space
right
and but you chose fiction as opposed to
doing a report or doing it in an in a
nonfiction way here's the question I
want to ask them and I want to get into
this area now how true to science does a
novel or a play or a movie have to be
and in turn and in what you did which is
essentially they're beautiful
meditations about time
how true did you have to be to what
Einstein really would have thought or
said well I felt like I didn't have to
be true at all and I mean one of the the
30 chapters deals with the actual theory
of relativity and the other 29 or
totally made up and my general point of
view on that is that that if you're
creating a work of art that is that has
a factual basis or is at least an
underpinning and of course they've been
many many of those I don't think that
the artist is obligated to be to portray
all of the facts accurately because it's
a work of art what you do have to deal
with is the fact that if you're dealing
with an historical figure like Albert
Einstein or Richard Fineman that many of
your readers or viewers are going to
know something about that figure right
so there's already a certain amount of
geography in their head dealing with
that person and if you if you write
something that's too dissonant with with
what's already in their head or create a
film or a play that's that's too
dissonant with what's already in their
head there's going to be a conflict that
you're going to have to deal with
somehow or another so you have to take
into account the fact that you're not
starting from a blank slate when you
deal with an historical figure that
doesn't mean you have to get every
biographical detail correct right right
and that and and with all of you I want
to actually brace this with all of you
but let me just for the moment go to
Anna and
did a couple of years ago so I hope some
of you might have been there at the
World Science Festival when there was a
we showed them you did a performance of
the play and I had the great honor of
interviewing James Watson and two
collaborators who were there at the time
and essentially they but they all three
started out by saying no it wasn't like
that at all no it wasn't like that at
all
and then they two of them came around
and Watson never did you were sitting in
the audience
uh-huh what is that like for you to hear
these guys say no no she got it all
wrong just good that I wasn't on the
panel in the audience um no I mean I
think well for one thing when I wrote
this play and as I said I was quite
young and I was a tiny Commission for a
tiny theater I never dreamed of the F of
the idea that some of the actual players
I was depicting would see the play one
day I never dreamed of the fact that you
know Rosalind Franklin's family members
would see this play so I didn't feel the
burden of of depicting I wasn't trying
to to create to imitate who these people
seem to be in life and I in fact I think
it's almost impossible to do so you can
you can read and research and maybe
maybe find some essence of these people
but if you didn't know them you didn't
know them and and the I think
responsibility is then first to
entertain and to create a palette of
characters who do interesting things
with each other and get interesting
things out of each other and so I think
while it's never fun to have the actual
people say oh gosh that wasn't how it
was I I suppose at the time I was first
of all really just kind of thrilled they
were there and second of all you know
didn't really feel like that was
necessarily what I was going for and
then there were some fireworks on that
panel as well about misogyny and about
the way they treated rosalind Franklin
right I mean I was gonna say what ended
up happening was I thought they ended up
kind of getting to a point of argument
that that then kind of validated the
play yes they were
all kind of disagreeing about what had
actually happened about robbing with
rosalind Franklin which is precisely
what the characters in the play do so it
actually I thought in a sort of funny
way ended up being quite a parallel to
what
yes performance yes Ville had just seen
of Alan Alda let me ask you about that
does does the art have to be critically
specifically factual I I think the
science has to be as correct as possible
the who the people are and what they do
and how they behave i I have a personal
preference to make it as close to what
really happened as possible and
sometimes it gets in my way again my own
preference gets in my way
I was looking at Murray a couple of days
ago at the play I wrote and some of the
parts I liked the best were the things I
totally made up and did anybody catch
you on that ask you and did you have you
know letters to the editor a tweet an
email saying this is everything I made
so little up I mean I used her own words
right and she said many things that were
extremely emotional she wrote a diary to
her dead husband for the whole year and
some of those passages are heartbreaking
so that was that was I mean I couldn't
match her writing in her real life right
it um tell me also about playing Fineman
how much in your head did you feel I
have to look like I'm I have to have the
right gestures I have tonight it not
almost not at all I tried to get an
accent close to his Far Rockaway accent
but I don't think even a Far Rockaway
accent I think he made it up
his sister doesn't talk like that at all
and I I think he he is a man of the
people and one it was a man of the
people wanted to present themselves that
way and I think there were people who
came back and said to me you know I'm
from Far Rockaway that's not the way
I know neither does he but I didn't try
to do an impersonation I tried you know
as you said before it tried to get the
essence the essence of it Matt Brown
your film was shown at Trinity College
where Rama Newton was and at the Royal
Society he famously became a fellow at
both we were a little nervous about the
reaction then I was we I was nervous
about it there was a funny story we were
um we were shooting a scene where
Ramanujan gets a fellowship at Trinity
and we were a low-budget independent
film and I had about two takes per scene
at times it was challenging and we had
this one scene and all my actors decided
to surprise me and knock on the table
you know for when they come in to give
him the fellowship as like the high
praise and and I just sat there and I
said oh no I've got time for like one
more shot and I don't know if that's
historically accurate or not and and I
was like we better just go with it and
it works emotionally and we're gonna
stick with this so they showed the film
at at Trinity and I was wondering what
they were gonna say and I guess and
nobody nobody brought it up so I don't
know if it's now gonna be tradition at
Trinity a said we were the first film to
get permission to shoot at Trinity
College which was quite an honor and it
was pretty amazing because when I gave
him the script they had a lot of racism
and it didn't portray them an especially
kind light but they they decided this
was an important story and they wanted
to tell it and they gave us they gave us
permission and they said well you can
shoot here but you can shoot everywhere
but the rent library and I was like well
I don't want to be the guy to burn the
rent library down so that is just fine
and we snuck down the road to Oxford and
shut the library there well talked about
you know you're being very starkly
accurate by telling us about it now so
Peter for now let's talk about trumpery
a little bit sure Charles Darwin was not
around to fact-check that one but his
biographer was right
yeah actually I got interested in Darwin
through Alfred Russel Wallace who I read
about and I was very interested in the
fact that these two that a scientist
of whom was sort of well-off and the
other Foom was actually working for him
as a specimen hunter that these two
scientists in two different parts of the
world essentially came up with the
theory of natural selection and Wallace
sent his abstract his first essay to
Darwin Darwin hadn't published yet and
he was going through a lot of we don't
know whether his how much cycle with his
illnesses were psychosomatic he was
working on on the origin species for 20
years and he got he freaked out and he
thought he would be for stalled he wrote
to his colleagues and had this essay
with him anyway I got very interested in
the fact of what is it it's about ideas
and what how do ideas come in are they
through one person only and what and but
I did a lot of research and the great
Darwin biography is by Janet Brown it's
a - it's a two-volume you know a
thousand page book that it's fantastic
and what's one of the things that's so
great is you do feel that you are sort
of in the Darwin's world and in that
study at down house and that the day is
day in and day out all of the
experiments all of the the things he was
doing with his children with his wife
working on this problem this problem
that it's just it was overwhelming to me
and I I did use it I read a lot of other
books but I did use her book and with
the show the play was done at the
Atlantic Theatre and the night before at
the end of its run my husband just and I
were having dinner near the theatre and
we went back to just to see the end of
the play to see the second act and usher
came up to and said there's a Miss Brown
who is looking for you and I just I
really really terrified
Janet Brown now teaches at Harvard and
she she'd read about to play an
interview I had done in the science
times and came to see it and it was
really fantastic we had dinner after
and then became friends and and I I
spoke about the play at the Darwin
Festival in 2009 at her invitation so
that turned out really well but I you
know it's you never know and and I got
was very very scared about it but it was
ended happily
Allan Lichtman let me give you the last
word on this part of it which is there
were a couple of movies in the opening
clip of clips of movies in the opening
video the Martian and then of course we
have interstellar there's a bunch of
movies that have become very popular and
people say scientists have said science
is not quite right I mean in the Martian
even Andy wire the author has said it's
true there couldn't be a storm like that
on Mars but and an interstellar is that
really wouldn't work what a wormhole is
and how it works
does it matter in terms of conveying the
message that you want to convey to get
the science right yeah no I mean I I
agree with Alan here that the science
part should be right but I think that
that what everybody here is saying is is
that the message that we're trying to do
and works of art as opposed to
documentaries the message we're trying
to do is to convey something about the
human side of science and the culture
that the of science the world that
scientists live in the way that
scientists think and so I don't think
that for that message that all of the
science has to be right right there
might be other considerations or which
would be a matter of opinion as to
whether the science needs to be right
but the message that you're trying to
convey in a work of art as opposed to
like that order decreases if you're
trying to convey the second law of
thermodynamics the message I think that
we're all trying to convey here is the
human landscape of scientists and and
and the way scientists are as people and
and in order to convey that you've got
to get
them in the theater or to buy the book
or to watch to listen to read my
question Peter let me turn it to you how
do you approach making one of these
extraordinary figures popular enough
interesting enough likeable enough
approachable enough that you can get
that you can a get financing in some
cases but or think you can get people do
want to come and see it's not a football
hero it's not an entertainment hero it's
a different kind of everyone we're
dealing with yes but again I mean I
think in you know do all of these cases
you're talking about hopefully good
storytelling which does involve some
very basic things that audiences can you
know climb in with what do audiences
want ask the filmmaker
that's a heart that's a you know i
audiences want to be surprised and they
want to be obviously engaged do they
want a good story isn't it's as simple
as that at some level yeah I guess so I
mean that's I have to really that's a
that's a really you know it's an
interesting Matt do you want to take a
stab at that yeah I mean I think I think
the good stories a big a good place to
start I think a story is very important
I don't know if I entirely agree about
the authenticity argument I think that I
think it I think it is really important
that the science is right at least as a
filmmaker for me it's been that the
mathematics has been right with this
film if if it wasn't right I think I
would have lost a whole audience thing
that is so happy and it means so much to
them tell them what you told me before
about the Princeton Institute Advanced
Studies screening we showed the film
it's been incredible the the response
that I never took it for granted that
the mathematics community would would
people said well the people like math
will watch your movie and I was like I
don't know let's see and and they've
embraced it so we showed the we showed
the film to Institute of Advanced
Studies and and this sort of speaks to
what you were saying before is you can't
ever you don't know these people you
know how do you really know what they're
like but so an older
comes up to me afterwards and he goes
well yogi I knew Hardy and this is the
movie set in 1914 and a new party and
you've got it all wrong
but you got it all right and and what he
meant by that
it was Freeman Dyson and Freeman
he said that Hardy's personality was
slightly different so how do you ever
really know what they're like and he
said that his sense of humor was
inappropriate in the way that maybe
wasn't conveyed in this film but he said
that the essence of it was all right and
that the mathematics was all correct and
that it meant so much to him that to see
math met mathematicians portrayed
authentically and correctly so to that
end I think it it matters I think from
film to film it matters I mean is it
important for the interstellar to be a
hundred percent right I don't know where
star wars but but is it important for
these kinds of stories that we're
talking about maybe it is I think it is
Alan Alda our plays about scientist
screenplays a tougher sell in Hollywood
than anything else I don't know I
haven't sold a movie to Hollywood I
think I think you have to be lucky with
any kind of a play that you get it on
and that people go see it and the end
that it's worth seeing you have to be
lucky in every way and you may even have
to be a little luckier if it's about
science because a lot of people assume
that science a play about science will
be didactic and not human and not
engaging but I think I think when you
search for the human story and you show
somebody trying to achieve something of
great value against terrific obstacles
it's hard to take your eyes off that
person you want that person to succeed
or if it's a bad person you want them to
fail which is which is about the story
and about the individual we're showing
them an image from I believe this is
raid up this is radiant
yeah ready with and so does it help when
you have Liev Schreiber and Maggie
Gyllenhaal to play roles yeah I mean we
had an incredible cast that night and it
was it was it was fun for me to hear the
words and they just set and sad and read
them they did it as a reading they
didn't get up and act it out but it was
I've seen it done now with a number of
casts some of them really extraordinary
actors and it's I don't know if you guys
have had this feeling the first time we
did a staged reading of it where they
were in costume in Seattle and they were
carrying scripts but they came out the
women came out in their long 19th 1906
presence my heart stopped
uh-uh we should I thought there's Murray
there was such a wonderful feeling it
was like a kid is it let me let me
rephrase the question I asked you before
is it harder to sell a play about
science than a movie about science do
you think where is moving easier they're
both very hard it's very it's really
isn't it amazingly hard to get either
one made I mean I think we you spent how
many years yeah that's true of almost
any kind of movie doesn't matter whether
it's about science or not no I get that
yeah but this but the subject is talk a
little bit about Hollywood seems to like
a story about a lone wolf the individual
fighting against the odds Pio Alan
you're shaking your head I mean I guess
I'm thinking about the the Alan Turing
the Stephen Hawking movies are these
does something like that I mean do you
have to go find a science just like that
can we do that if you don't have a lone
character that you can identify with
it's very difficult to tell the story
but does it have to be a lone wolf does
it what do you think Alan does it have
to be or and could you do a group would
have group well I think it's very hard
to make a movie about a committee
Warren Commission I didn't mean to
interrupt you go ahead I don't know if
you want to answer that I don't know if
you have an answer well I think having I
agree that having a single central
character makes life easier I don't know
whether that person has to be struggling
against the establishment to make an
interesting story I think there are
other ways they could be they could be
having an inner struggle it would also
make an interesting story and I think
what you were talking about with with
Fineman and his later life was an inner
struggle that you were describing Peter
you've got a TV series coming up a TV
show which is a sitcom no no no it's I'm
one of the writers on and I didn't
create it okay but it's a no it's a show
called brain-dead it will be on in two
weeks it's about it's it's from Michelle
Robert King who created and where the
head writers of The Good Wife and but
it's very different and it's a political
satire mixed with science fiction so and
very much in a way of the moment it's
said that in the Senate and it is about
really about political extremism and
what happens when the extreme right and
the extreme left are unable to speak to
each other and so it's really never yeah
it's about the inability to the
difficulty of governing and if having
change happen within the system so much
of what we see on television reflects
what's going on occasionally it leads us
were you surprised about the success of
the Big Bang Theory that here's a bunch
of young science nerds who are suddenly
the hottest show television yeah gosh
well I mean you have a reaction to that
I mean these are scientists and the
world loves it or maybe none of you
watches television no no we just move on
that's fully funny you know
aren't that many shows that are
successfully funny
it is funny you a Nicole Kidman stored
in photograph 51 in London in the West
End is that right back to the same
question about getting an audience once
again getting a big star like Nicole
Kidman does that help to get this out
there so you'd help yeah I mean no I
mean it's actually sort of funny is that
the producers in England I had no idea
that the play had had a somewhat
substantial life in the United States
before before they got their hands on it
I think it had had 1012 productions here
and one in New York that had been
reviewed you know so it was it was kind
of out there and getting some momentum
on its own but but they oh how they got
it is one of those really roundabout
sort of you know sort of random showbiz
stories it was like michael grandage who
was the director and also the producer
had seen a different play of mine in
england at a tiny pub theatre years ago
and so i think i was a little bit on his
radar because of that and then and then
when photograph 51 was getting some
traction here i think one of his donors
he used to run the Donmar Warehouse and
one of his big donors who was it an
American couple had seen the play in
Washington DC and I think that's how
they got how he read it I don't think I
got it to him I don't I'm not sure
things over happening that Nicole Kidman
is not a closeted scientist well she
actually she I think when he pitched it
to her I think it did hold special
appeal because her father was a
scientist oh so there was she in fact is
sort of a closeted scientist in a way so
it did it did have some again the
commencement address especially the day
right after is it rosalind Franklin
University asset saga at school in
Chicago why did you tell the students
that resonated that could resonate
Sam about her life yeah um well I mean I
I think I was in thinking about it
really struck by and writing the speech
really struck by the idea that this
university had elected to name itself
after someone who did not come in first
and who was overlooked for a long time
and and so it made me think about how
you know we're not it's sort of cheesy
but not the some of our achievements and
and that what she stood for which was an
incredible integrity and and and kind of
I think similar to Curie never giving up
and and really enjoying the science she
was really she would work for years on
projects with no end in sight and and in
some ways was the ideal scientist
because she would not there was a line I
wanted to put in my address that I took
out but that she so did not want to put
the cart before the horse that sometimes
people ran away with her horse you know
that she she just she couldn't she did
not want to be wrong she wanted to have
that kind of integrity and so I I saw I
talked about that a little bit and and
also I think on the flip side the lesson
one can take from her life is that there
are risks that that we should take that
she didn't take for many reasons and
legitimate ones and I don't judge her in
fact I she's a hero of mine but I like I
like the message that even if you come
in second you can get a school named
after you exactly yeah we're gonna open
it up for questions in just a minute but
let me let me see I would bet in this
audience there are some people who might
be thinking of writing a play about an
individual and might be looking to a
scientist to fictionalize their lives
advice what do you tell somebody who
wants to do that sort of thing out I
would say make sure you fall in love
with the person you're writing about
because you're gonna spend a lot of time
with that person
and you have to give them the chance to
be who they are and you won't do it
unless you're in love with them because
they'll be truculent from time to time
and they'll do things you don't like and
you have to go along with them and let
them be who they are that I mean along
those lines I think you have to have
true passion for if you're gonna do it
because it's a long ride whether it's a
film or at play so I think you'll
discover that on your own but you'll
find that if you go a little distance
you'll have that real passion because I
don't think you can fake it it's gotta
come from in your heart I can't fake it
absolutely uh-huh well I would say find
a character who has an interesting story
in there there are a lot of great
scientists who for one reason or there
don't have lives that would lend
themselves to dramatic rendering but I
think also that the interesting story
should have a message that that you feel
passionate about and just like Allen
says that you should fall in love with
the character I think that you should
feel passion for the message and the
story that you want to tell Peter yeah I
know I think that's I would I would just
add I think to not be afraid to try to
touch what is personal to try to figure
out why you are invested so and in love
with this character because ultimately
and it does speak a bit to what both
Allen's and what matt has not have been
saying ultimately I don't I think you're
you're capturing an aspect or a part of
this scientist but you are also actually
writing about yourself on some level you
may not have to fully understand it but
don't be afraid to engage that part of
yourself because it's the personal thing
that makes you want to return and be in
love with this particular character or
character right the wonderful advice
Anna I agree very tight with all of that
I think I would only add in terms of
looking for material that um
contested Nobel prizes are very good
places people with some bones to pick so
there's so many of those stories out
there oh good well we could go on all
day I even have more questions but I
want to give you folks an opportunity
perhaps the lights can come up and if
you have questions I think there are two
people with microphones will be
circulating oh my god
[Laughter]
I overheard yes hello hi hi so I know
this whole time we've been talking about
the human element and the individual and
the character and you're saying that's
you know you'll have an easier time are
there any examples in film or plays or a
novel where they managed to you know
portray science it's some sort of
dramatized form and there were and there
wasn't a person involved it wasn't a
central figure I mean you're all saying
that would be very difficult that
anybody managed to pull it off by
science without a scientist basically or
drama but science drama without a
scientist anybody think of one there's a
book I liked by Allegra Goodman called
intuition which is set in a science lab
in Cambridge that is not about it's not
about a famous scientist it's a purely
fiction that I think or I've been told
both depicts the world of science very
accurately and I think tells a pretty
compelling story that's what I'm AG
d-done sure I think yeah of course thank
you more questions back here yes hi my
favorite science movie is dr. Alex magic
bullet I think it's like combo you get a
lot of science and you got the biography
what's yours
favorite science movie who wants to take
that I don't see any hands going up you
could say dr. Strangelove that sort of
science I love Matt's movie and I
that's them that's the most reason what
I've seen but it's it's thoroughly
lovable I mean there there's all the
elements were talking about a human
story and you walk away thinking you
understand something about deep math and
that's that's an amazing accomplishment
thank you and your favorite science
movie oh gosh I don't know I I don't
have a particular one on hand okay I'm
luckily I won't make everybody answer
unless somebody wants to I love The
Matrix and I I mean it's not about the
scientists and it's not about the world
we live in it's science fiction but I
think it has very interesting ideas and
a very imaginative and we haven't talked
about Copenhagen and we haven't talked
about proof I feel proof was a very
interesting human story but I didn't
think there was much math in it I mean
when I walked out it didn't have the
feeling that I did when I walked out of
your movie that I had touched math and
been touched by her it was it could have
been about I thought it could and I'm
not denigrating it for this but it could
have been about a business that had been
taken over by somebody rather than a
thesis right it didn't have to be
science didn't have to be but how about
Copenhagen Copenhagen certainly it was a
lot of science a lot of science in there
and I'm gonna volunteer the Martian
because I love the Martian I think I
love the book I love the movie I thought
it was they did a great job and and that
and and bringing science up to the
forefront of that just to turn people
into scientists and to care about
scientists science I thought was amazing
the other Allen dude did you think that
the storm on Mars was a bad thing to do
and that it was it okay even though it
couldn't happen I mean that's an
interesting situation where they were
criticized for having a storm on Mars
and it was a critical moment in the
story but it couldn't happen apparently
did that didn't bother me because there
could have been other catastrophes on
Mars that would have produced the same
story and so I think that I considered
that to be a detail and everything else
was was totally convincing to me yeah
hardly anybody stood up at the screening
I was at complain yeah but then you
didn't see it with a lot of massive
people little bit more question is
somebody back here yes all right you
have a mic nice thank you everyone for
being here I'm in the software industry
and I have a very similar challenge if
you were play scientists with the
software engineers we have a hard time
sometimes conveying certain feature sets
or certain reasons of why we want to
code websites or software to do certain
things and we have to use story in the
same way so we're going to ask when you
were trying to convey the technical
science pieces and your plays and your
in the movie as well did you try to do
the minimum amount of technical
explanation and more story to convey
that type of message for example of
using formulas or whatever the case may
be or did you go full fledged into the
technical explanations and hope that the
audience would understand what you were
trying to convey Mac well I hope that
some of it would play in a subtext when
I was writing because I knew that there
was no way that that people were gonna I
mean most people are gonna understand
pure mathematics or what they're talking
about but I thought that I'd put it into
the dialogue and I thought that we would
get the essence and sometimes it would
it would sort of line up in a way that
sub textually it was playing I mean like
partitions just the idea of what
partitions is and these to such
different people it kind of when they
were talking about certain things
sometimes in going there with it and not
shying away from it I felt like we kind
of got to a place that was we knew as an
audience what was
going on I think that there were some
people that were more concerned that I
was doing that but the the audiences
didn't seem to mind it at all and in
fact if there's something I've learned
from this whole thing as they wish I had
even gone deeper with it so you know you
wish you would put more math into this
well I think some people wish that I had
gone a little bit deeper with it in
places where you know I felt very
comfortable with with the level that we
went to and and not exceeding but I
think that there have been people that
wish that it even had gone deeper so
every night when we did QED I was amazed
and grateful that Peter could get so
much quantum electrodynamics into this
play and the audience watched it with
interest and involvement did I mean were
you were you surprised at how am I able
to do there yes Alan but also you were
you were wonderful and but I think no I
just I do think that in that this in the
case of QED the form of the play was
allowing Fineman to teach us and so
there was a certain amount and we would
go over and we and it took you know we
worked it and reworked it so that it
would feel seamless but sometimes
Fineman was thinking about something
else but he was using what what you're
saying is interesting in terms of
translating into software because having
a character who was teaching it him sort
of takes care of that issue interesting
yes down a front here comes some like I
am not really off topic but then you've
written amazing biography of Sally Ride
and I have to say like most people when
I read a biography of someone I know
it's really hard not to like it and to
think you got it wrong and I think you
did a fantastic job is anybody doing a
movie or a play thank you for saying
that I promise you were not related I've
never met them
yeah it's a sony HBO or doing a movie
out of it it'll be a multi-part TV movie
thank you which I am not writing that
will be about to the next you know I'll
discuss but what I want to do next with
these guys later more questions yes in
let's go in the back there
we haven't been all the way in the back
yeah thank you so dr. Lightman you
brought up the book by Italia Covino
which is a favorite book of mine but I
was wondering if you can comment on this
like kind of resolution between like the
post modernist thought of art that kind
of clashes with like this scientific
materialists thought that you're so
engrained with within the field so I was
wondering if that was a problem maybe
trying to resolve these two philosophies
and also the panel as well trying to
like combine the fields of art and
science are things that clash so often
is there any of you can comment on that
struggle well I I'm not sure what the
post modernist clash is but I I do agree
with with Matthew and Alan that the the
science and a work of art that has
science and it should be correct and
when I was talking about that the artist
was not obligated to to follow all the
factual material I was talking about the
the the the life and society surrounding
the science some of the biography of the
people involved but I there's there's a
an opening scene of Don DeLillo's great
novel underworld in which we're at a
baseball game and it's a famous
historically famous baseball game is the
Yankees against somebody I think it's a
World Series I'm actually from Boston so
it should have been the Boston Red Sox
[Laughter]
but anyway in the audience as I remember
right DeLillo
places Frank Sinatra and J Edgar Hoover
and one or two other famous historical
characters that that almost certainly
were
they're at the game and is that is that
a clash or not is that allowable it's
it's a fantastic novel and it adds color
and I think that it that that the a work
of art is also is permitted to do that
that that you can't let the facts get in
the way of your imagination and when I
was writing Einstein's dreams I did not
want to visit the city of Bern while I
was writing the book because I didn't
want the facts of the city to to inhibit
my imagination too much when I was
finished I sent the first draft to
people who lived and burn to make sure
that I hadn't gotten things very wrong
but in creating the the book I sort of
tried to respect my imagination and so
so I I believed that that the
imagination the creative imagination has
to come first in the kind of art that
we're talking about I mean there's
plenty of vehicles for presenting
science factually they're documentaries
there's Nova there are lots of other
wonderful books by great science writers
and I think that that that using the
work of art where your primary focus is
to get all of the science is is to teach
science I think it's like using a hammer
to screw in or using a screwdriver to
hammer a nail that you've got the wrong
vehicle you've got the wrong tool so um
well I think it's very important to get
the scientific facts right I think that
we should honour our imagination and
creating the rest of the work is to
Lillo dead with underworld well let's
take a couple more questions let's take
one from back here yes
I guess my question is for Alan Alda you
have it seems like ever since I've seen
you on screen been trying to convey
accurate science and marry human nature
with science and just try to make it a
melding versus like a clash what
inspired you to start doing that I don't
know I'd love I've been curious since I
was a little boy and I did not
I was not encouraged in that curiosity
by the people who taught me biology in
high school or mathematics it was just
when I got into my early 20s and started
reading Scientific American and other
and books about science that I could
follow my curiosity wherever it led I
guess in a way the way a scientist
follows his or her curiosity and and
actually does science but for me it was
just a beautiful wonderful fun
experience and exploration and when I
was doing the program Scientific
American frontiers where I must have
interviewed about 700 scientists I
realized that this conversational
approach we took brought the real them
out and they were human and engaging
because we were just improvising
together
it wasn't responding to a set of
questions it was a real live
conversation and I think that all added
to my my wish to bring that in other
forms to this stage but it also helped
me decide that I thought I had something
to offer scientists and helping them
make their stories clear to the public
and to Congress who doesn't know what
they're talking I told you we're not a
doctor
yeah they've spent their lives to
learning other things inside
tonight I just have to make it clear to
them back here yes thank you so
something that I think gets to continue
the conversation that kind of just began
here something that we keep coming back
to is sort of engaging audiences and how
to engage audiences in these
conversations and so I'm wondering what
the role of artists are and storytellers
are in terms of science literacy and so
a scientific list literacy and sort of
the literacy of our society that we as
storytellers have I'm kind of curious to
hear from everyone about you're asking
let me see what's the role of the artist
and the storyteller in terms of
scientific literacy Allen do you you're
shaking your head as if you want to
answer that that Allen um well anybody
can answer that no Hey
okay well I but you you have a unique
position of being both the science and
literate well I think that's that's
different from what we've been talking
about here because I think if your goal
is science literacy so you're truck
trying to actually teach science and
that's your main mission then I think
that's that that you use every means at
your disposal and I think storytelling
is an excellent means for doing that
with their there are some wonderful
examples of successful conveying science
successfully with storytelling but I
don't think that that's the the
principal motive of science literacy of
what we've been talking about here am I
wrong
no I think you're right because science
I don't see a fact as opposed to what
you're doing what you all are doing
which is storytelling as a vehicle for
fiction there's also the blurry edge of
science literacy where it's where you
don't become a scientist because you're
scientifically literate but you think a
little bit more
as scientists you regard the evidence as
important you have an awareness of how
science is done so that you don't say
the year ago they said coffee was bad
for you now they say it's good for you
so they don't know what they're talking
about well if you understand a little
bit more about how science is done you
realize they're not looking for the
truth they're looking for more truth and
you're with them in their quest it's
it's so interesting and I will take a
couple of more questions from the
audience
in just a second I keep thinking about
the thing that was so hot when I was
probably I think in high school which
was CP snow and that and the divided
world and the two the two cultures thank
you
the divided culture and it was science
over here and it was humanities over
here and schools and certainly after
Sputnik went up there was a big effort
to get more science but are we are we be
just on that point and and and take it
into the fictional world if you want but
are we trying to get beyond that are we
beyond that are we any closer to
bringing the two cultures together do
you think that a little closer I mean
it's it's a little closer you the two
movies that were up for Academy Awards
last year were science films so which it
does just for filming but right it does
it does meld the two worlds I I think
that there's this like I'm totally in
agreement with you about storytelling
and creativity and it should be
unhampered and you should be able to do
whatever you want to do as an artist a
hundred percent that said there is also
this incredible opportunity of outreach
and this incredible opportunity to tell
sums true stories and and get them out
to the world and and and there's
something wonderful about that does that
mean that every story needs to be 100%
authentic no I don't think so I mean you
you can do whatever you want to do so
it's about chipping away a little bit to
bring these two worlds together to get
people comfortable I think so I think
it's amazing I think it's amazing that
for a general audience to go to a movie
about mathematics or a general audience
to learn about Turing or to learn about
Hawking's even if they have to go way on
this
of the human story to get it out there I
think it's a good thing because we're
all people and and science shouldn't be
on this side and in humanities on that
it's and there was a time I remember
movies in the 40s that sometimes dealt
with great scientists and they told a
compelling human story which was free to
be fictional as much as they chose but
they also felt free to make the science
as fictional as virtual and I think
there's less of a regard for that kind
of behavior now I think I think that
there's more attention paid to accuracy
in science it's a little harder to do
but you if you find out what the real
facts are and try to make the story work
with the real facts of the science or
the medicine it's more exciting you have
to work that really hard or completely
agree with you yeah and you do have to
work harder though that's that I think
is harder yeah let's let's take two more
questions if we may over here
oh sorry then we'll come over here it's
somebody oh hey I didn't see thank you
oh hello um my question is there have
been very few movies that the main
character are alive why are the
production of the films such as Stephen
Hawking the theory of everything our
doctor patch Adams um do you think would
be easier harder to make a movie if the
main character was alive or are harder
interesting does does being dead make it
easier to get a movie made about you
contradictions do you think they would
be okay that there'll be some fiction in
their lives in the movie for it well you
had a living person in your play yeah I
have - I have three now yes no I mean I
think it certainly creates more
obstacles
not to mention sort of Rights wise but I
uh you know I think there are a lot of
people who would be thrilled
have a movie made about them and and
where where that wouldn't you know
wouldn't be an issue but but certainly
it would make your job harder Anna don't
you think I know I think you would feel
the responsibility in a deeper way to
try to be true to that person and not to
depict them in such a negative light I
mean I think that that might be the
tricky thing is to is to tamp down the
need to be wholly positive about someone
who's still living because of course you
want to depict them in the way that they
really are which is complicated it does
sort of make it hard on the scientist
though if they have to die in order to
get the movie it's a bummer let's take
one more question over here yes
hi I'd love you to all talk a little bit
about the challenge of actually getting
the science after the story is written
getting that science onto the screen or
onto the stage and as background we won
a contest by the National Academy of
Engineering called the next MacGyver
contest to try and get a female MacGyver
engineering character onto television
now that we've finished the story we're
at the beginning of that journey and
it's really difficult to convince people
that that's going to be something that
people want to see so how did you guys
do it
you want to hear the pitch right yeah
Matt you're probably you've done it most
recently it's hard it's it's I mean I
had an Indian mathematician at the turn
of the century know you know there is no
white nurse and there was a love story
with his wife at home it was really
really difficult and as a result of it
I'm actually beginning a foundation
right now to try to make more films in
an authentic fashion that have to deal
with the world of steam because I don't
ever want to go through that again and I
don't want anyone else to so I I don't
really have a good answer for it other
than it's just perseverance but I think
that there's incredible stories to be
told we were actually considering doing
a story about a monoid her the female
mathematician who had to publish under
males a male's you know name to get it
done and that that doesn't get made by
Hollywood I mean it just doesn't so I
don't I think it's just persevere
and piecing things together and not
giving up and I don't know what else to
say it's hard
anybody else have advice Peter uh yeah I
agree with Matt I don't I mean I think
you some of it is what you first put on
the page and then as you're working I
assume with actors and from the camera
certainly on stage you work it and
rework it so that it is clearer and so
that it does feel like it's all of a
piece and and it's not you don't get it
the first time I mean it takes it takes
what I'll give you a something that I
learned by experience they the people
who guard the gate the ones who had the
money the networks the channels that
will buy it want to make sure that
they'll get viewers so they'll probably
want your leading character to be a
really dominant figure in the play the
whole play has to be has to show off
that person's acting talent and it has
to be a big star so you need to get the
involvement of the the actor or actors
right away and a director who can make
it happen
that they're that they're felt they
they'll be crazy about you have to put
it together and then they'll fall all
over you no better advice than that and
the sloan foundation Doren's here they
were very supportive you're welcome I
thought she was gonna go to your
foundation oh I'm sorry we're just
starting a different kind of one but I
mean these guys gave us don't back out
now they proceeded money for our film
that was you know very very helpful and
yeah but he's right you need a good
actor so and then that will be part of
the panel the next time around there you
go
thank you to a wonderful audience thank
you to an extraordinary panel thank you
for all the movies and films and
lazy done and thank you thank you thank
you for helping us all to understand
that scientists are just people too
thank you you were terrific
[Music]
[Music]